-The President is lying
about the Mueller report
as his son, Don Jr., is facing
a congressional subpoena.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Last night, President Trump
held a rally in Florida
where he once again lied
about Special Counsel
Robert Mueller's report,
which established
that Trump's campaign
had links to Russia
and benefited from
Russian interference
in the election
and that Trump repeatedly tried
to obstruct the investigation.
Remember? I mean every time
we talk about this story,
I have to restate
those basic facts,
facts that would,
in a sane world,
dominate the political landscape
for months, if not years.
Because everyone
keeps forgetting them.
And I'm not blaming anyone.
It's just
too much keeps happening.
While we were talking about
the Mueller report,
we found out that Trump lost
over a $1 billion in 10 years.
This [bleep] is distracting.
[ Laughter ]
It's like going to book club
where everyone
read a different book,
they all talk at the same time,
and instead of rosé,
people do uncut cocaine
while Skrillex plays.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We can't focus.
But the report was incredibly
damning for Trump.
For one thing,
the report was 448 pages.
If you went
to a parent-teacher conference
and the teacher said,
"Let me get your son's file,"
and it was 448 pages,
that kid's
going to military school.
[ Laughter ]
But Trump's been lying about it,
and he did so again last night
when he claimed
that the report exonerated him.
And he also claimed that
if he had investigated
anyone in the crowd
for two years,
he could have found crimes
in their backgrounds, too.
-Did you see what just happened,
by the way?
No collusion.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No obstruction.
No anything.
Two years on a witch hunt.
I could've gotten anybody
in this audience,
I could've
found something on you.
-Wow, that is an interesting
new political strategy.
[ Laughter ]
Accusing your own supporters
of being criminals.
He should start calling people
out like an insult comic.
"Check out that lady.
You telling me
you've never passed a bad check.
Look at her."
[ Laughter ]
"Big old fraud face."
For obvious reasons,
Trump wants to move on
from the Mueller report
as quickly as possible,
which is why he's waging
a war on Congress
to stop them from reading
the full, unredacted report
and all the underlying evidence.
Trump is also refusing
to hand over documents
and telling former aides
to defy subpoenas.
He is fundamentally lawless,
which is not surprising,
because the guy spent his whole
life getting away with stuff.
If you left work
every Friday early
to go golfing with Kid Rock,
your boss would be like,
"You're fired."
And also, Kid Rock plays golf?
[ Laughter ]
Seems like a bowling guy.
In fact,
at his rally last night,
Trump referenced a tweet
he had retweeted
suggesting that
he should get two more years
added onto his presidency,
and in the process
of attacking the media,
doubled down on the joke.
-They are a bunch of fakers.
There's no question about it.
But you know, in six years,
they're all gonna be
out of business, folks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're all
gonna be out of business.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Now, if we want
to drive them crazy,
I'll say in 10 years,
they'll go crazy.
"See, he is a despot.
He is a despot."
Well, 10 or 14.
Let's see.
Whatever we like, right?
Watch.
It'll be headlines tomorrow.
"Donald Trump
wants to break Constitution."
-You don't get credit
for predicting headlines
that you created.
[ Laughter ]
You can't rob a liquor store
and then say,
"Watch the media tomorrow.
It'll say, 'Oh,
he robbed a liquor store!'"
[ Laughter ]
"'He had a gun.
He was waving it around.'"
[ Applause ]
The Mueller report, it just
came out three weeks ago,
and Trump already wants
to cover it up and move on.
In fact, Trump is now citing
executive privilege
to block the release
of the full, unredacted report
and all the underlying evidence.
And yet he also keeps claiming
that the report
he doesn't want anyone to see
exonerates him.
And he did it again
during an event
at the White House
this afternoon.
-The report comes back,
it's perfect.
It's beautiful.
There's no collusion.
Nobody even
talks about collusion.
Do you know, I haven't heard the
word "Russia" in a long time.
There's no more talk
about Russia.
What happened to Russia?
The Russian witch hunt?
They don't talk about --
Because it was so on collusion,
which, by the way, is by far --
that's the big deal.
'Cause it was all about Russia.
So I haven't heard
the word "Russia."
They don't use
the word "Russia" anymore.
-Just because you don't hear
the word "Russia,"
doesn't mean
no one else uses it.
For one thing,
all you watch is Fox News,
where I'm pretty sure
they pretend
Russia doesn't even exist.
When they show a map
of Europe and Asia,
they replace Russia
with a graphic that says,
"What about Hillary's e-mails?"
[ Laughter ]
And yet no matter --
no matter --
[ Applause ]
No matter how much Trump
would like to move on,
the investigation
is very much not over.
In fact, we just
found out yesterday
that the Senate
Intelligence Committee,
whose chairman is a Republican,
had subpoenaed Donald Trump Jr.
to come back in and testify
again about some of the details
in the Mueller report.
And speaking to reporters today,
Trump made clear
he was not happy about that.
-I was very surprised
to see my son --
My son's a very good person,
works very hard.
The last thing he needs
is Washington, D.C.
Think he'd rather
not ever be involved.
Remember, he said to me,
a long time ago
when I was thinking
about running,
"Dad, if I can help,
let me know.
It's not my expertise.
-Here's my question --
what is his expertise?
[ Laughter ]
Because it's definitely not
business, politics, speaking,
spelling, writing, or standing.
I mean, look at this.
Why --
[ Laughter and applause ]
Why does this whole family
stand like a bunch of weirdos?
[ Laughter ]
Don Jr. looks likes
he's recording you
with a secret mic
strapped to his chest.
[ Laughter ]
"Could you say that
a little louder
and closer to my nipples?"
[ Laughter ]
"So, the meeting
did take place?"
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump and his son
are both mad about the subpoena.
In fact, CNN reported
that one option
Trump Jr. is considering
in response to the subpoena
is to invoke
his 5th amendment rights
and another is just
not to appear at all.
And if that happens,
one Democratic Senator said
they should enforce the subpoena
by any means necessary.
-If Donald Trump Jr.
defies this subpoena,
he ought to be jailed.
-Wow. I do not think Don Jr.
would fair well in jail.
I mean, for one thing,
can you imagine his hair
with only prison shampoo?
[ Laughter ]
So, we just got the Mueller
report three weeks ago,
and we're still waiting
for the full, unredacted version
as well as
all the underlying evidence.
Now is when the Congressional
response should start, not stop.
And yet Republicans want
to declare the whole thing over
and move on
as quickly as possible.
-Robert Mueller's
witch hunt found nothing.
And they were trying.
Mueller is done.
It's over.
-It's not even worth
talking about anymore.
I'm done with it.
-I'm not going to do any more.
Enough already.
It's over.
-The Special Counsel's
finding is clear.
Case closed.
[ Laughter ]
-It's really funny when
the least interesting
man in the world takes that long
a dramatic pause.
[ Laughter ]
He sounds like a ghost
drifting away in a graveyard.
"Case...closed."
[ Laughter ]
McConnell also said
in his speech
that he wanted to finally
end discussion
of the Russia investigation
once and for all.
-That's what I want
to discuss this morning.
Russia's interference
in American elections,
the work of the Special Counsel
and the Attorney General
and how we can finally end this
"Groundhog Day" spectacle.
-This isn't "Groundhog Day."
Every week,
we find out something new.
If anything,
we have too much information.
Following
the latest developments
in the Russia investigation
is like trying to piece together
the plot lines
of the last 20 Marvel movies.
"Okay, so that guy told that guy
to fire that guy.
But he said no
and told that other guy
he was gonna quit
so he wouldn't go to jail
like that other guy
who shared polling data
with that guy
while that one lawyer
was lying about
that other lawyer's deal
with that other guy.
And despite all this,
you're telling me
Paul Rudd hasn't aged a day
this whole time?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
The evidence is plain as day.
It's right in front of us.
In fact, this week,
hundreds of former prosecutors
signed a letter saying Trump
would've been indicted
if he weren't the president.
The letter is a nuanced,
in-depth legal argument,
But it can basically
be summed up in two words.
-Case closed.
Case closed.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]